يعني بالفعل صدر هذا الحكم يعني السجن بدى
الحياه وهو حكم حكم مشدد بمعنى انه لن يحق
له ان يطلب طلب مراجعه هذا الحكم واخلاق
سبيل بعد 15 عاما بل بعد 20 عاما يعني
عليه ان يقضي عشرين عاما في السجن قبل ان
يمكنه ان يطلب طلب اخلاء سبيل من المحكمه
لانه المؤبد في المانيا يعني ليس مؤبد مدى
الحياه ولكن يسمح للسجين بان يطلب اخلاء
سبيل بعد عشرين عام وهذا الحكم هو في
الواقع اقصى من الحكم الذي انزل بانور
رسلان الضابط السوري الذي صدر حكم بحقه
قبل عام في محكمه يعني مدينه اخرى في
المانيا انور رسلان كان ضابط مسؤول عن سجن
متهم بتعذيب وقتل عدد كبير من المعتقلين
السوريين انذاك ولكن هنا قالت القاضيه
بانه هذا الحكم انزل به مشدد لانه هو اطلق
هذه القذيفه على مجموعه من المدنيين
الذين كانوا يعانون من الجوع كانوا ضعفاء
وهو استغل هذا الضعف واطلق عليهم يعني
قذيفه ولم يتمكن عدد منهم من الهرب او حتى
من ان يحصلوا على يعني الاستشفاء بسبب
الحصار الذي كان قد ضرب على هذا المخيم
لذلك بالفعل الناشطون المدني الحقوقيون
هنا السوريون يعتبرونه حكم ثاني تاريخي
مهم جدا ويعطيهم دفعا لكي يستمروا في
المحاكمات او في القضايا الاخرى التي
يجمعونها لان هناك محاكمه ثالثه ايضا تجري
ما زالت جاريه بحق متهم يدعى علاء في
مدينه فرانكفيت على ما اعتقد وهو ايضا
متهم بانه هو كان طبيب في مستشفى عسكري في
سوريا ايام الحرب ومتهم ايضا بتعذيب وقتل
معتقلين تحت التعذيب هذه المحاكمه كما
ذكرت ما زالت جاريه ولم يصدر فيها حكم بعد
ولكن يعني هذه المحاكمه يعني تعطيهم ابدا
بانه بالف يمكنهم الاستمرار بجمع ادله
ومحاوله ايضا جلب متهمين اخرين امام
المحاكم الالمانيه